hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and welcome to this video on
order flow bitcoin analysis you know
this is the first video
that i've done on bitcoin
analysis with order flow um that i've
posted up on my youtube channel and you
know it's a question that i've gotten
over the years is
can order flow be used on bitcoin or
some of the other crypto markets and
yeah yes it it can you know it's a
market that trades in a basically in a
two-way auction right there's buyers and
they're sellers but more importantly you
know there's bidders
and there's
we won't call them
uh offers you know people working offer
so you have a working bid you have a
working offer so henceforth you have a
two-way auction and of course order flow
can be used and really the benefit of
using order flow in crypto is to see the
big size that goes through you know as
you know as we know right um the people
that can really move the market are the
big whales you know and oftentimes um
you know you see these guys like michael
saylor you know posting stuff on
um
twitter etc um you know microstrategies
you know buying x amount of bitcoin or
something but by the time that hits the
wires or hits twitter the trade often
already happened right he's not going to
say oh you know michael saylor's not
going to call and say yeah i'm buying
bitcoin
then
everyone's going to see that and come in
and rush it and start buying it but if
you're watching the order flow you know
you can see these big transactions go
through sort of unnoticed because if
you're looking at a simple bar chart
right you're not going to
see
um you know where the volume is taking
place
in the transactions right it's just not
going to show up in there you can't tell
how much traded here you know at the
price of um you know 47
way back here right you just can't
you're not looking at the volume but on
the footprint chart you can see
precisely the volume that traded now
i use ninjatrader ninjatrader has
access to the coinbase feed okay now
coinbase is not the biggest exchange in
the world but you know it's one of the
biggest
and more importantly you know the data
feed is free and it's real time
okay so again if you're a ninjatrader
user just go to connections and you can
go in and set it up right in here okay
simple and again it's it's free
real-time data
and you know it's quite fascinating to
watch the order flow this morning
or around lunch time you know we had
this big drop
we get down to about 46 600 when we're
trading almost a thousand dollars higher
just a little bit earlier you know this
is a 15 minute chart um a little bit
earlier
maybe an hour earlier we're trading 47
600 so we dropped about a thousand
dollars and then rallied back up and
if you're looking at the order flow you
know there's
sometimes it's just very clear sign when
you understand what's happening in the
market
okay because order flow is the only
method out there that's going to show
you the actual volume that's traded on
the bid and the volume traded on the
offer you know the thing with these
exchanges like coinbase and kraken and
all the all the exchanges right they
have their trading front end which shows
you the time and sales right of the
trades going through well you know the
problem is it just moves too fast okay i
mean
what good is that for you as a trader
right if you're watching
you know the time in sales well
so what you know everything is going
through at
and especially in bitcoin you know you
can buy any amount of bitcoin that you
want really what you want to see in my
opinion is the amount of bitcoin right
and
that's what matters right you don't care
that you know someone bought 15 20
you know
that's such a small part of a bitcoin
but when you can see things like here
right this was today around nine o'clock
you know 8 45 9 o'clock time let me open
this chart up a little bit bigger
might be a little bit hard to see on
this video but there's 166 coins traded
right here so what happened is the
market went up got all the way up to you
know 48 120
started coming down
and there was buyers here i mean people
actively putting bids in the market
there was 166 that traded here 27
69 87. normally you'd see this type of
size come in and
you think it's supportive of the market
right because that's what um you know
200 300
close to you know about 350 bitcoin
right in here between you know around
the 47
900 down to about you know the 47
850 level right that's a lot of bitcoin
at that time period
for any time during the day
so you would think that would be
supportive and it couldn't hold up the
market right market even sold off a
little bit lower from these levels from
the 47 900 got down to you know 47 600
rallied back up but on this rally back
up here right so i know i had what do we
know okay we know we've got some
big buyers coming in around this 47 900
level okay so now when we sold off from
that we didn't rally right it didn't
hold up the market
okay
so someone
or someone or a group of people whatever
came in and actively bid because this
was an area that we were trading at for
the last hour and a half prior to
getting to this bar
market sold off it starts coming back up
now we're not seeing
really the big buying coming in here
right second time around you're
imagining right people that were buying
it here market drops okay maybe they
bought some more at lower levels looking
for this market to go up finally gets
back up to that level gets through it
but it's not doing it on much volume
okay i mean you can see as it's trading
up here it's you know half of a bitcoin
is two bitcoin
two bitcoin and it comes off right then
the next bar opens up makes another run
at it again small volumes you know a
half of a bitcoin point four of a
bitcoin one bitcoin three
eleven so now okay there's some offers
but the big tell
you know the big tell for people that
watch order flow
is this this 54 here
this 52 here
okay because when the market starts
dropping right you'd imagine
that
aggressive sellers you know people
coming in selling the bids right people
hitting the bids moving the market
lower
okay which is
obviously a sign of a market going down
right that's how markets move is when
the aggressive sellers come into the
market
but what you have here you got 54
bitcoin traded here right you got
another 52 here right and
you know these are the ones that stand
out obviously you got 17 12 11. those
are smaller numbers but 54 here 52 here
so
this is the area right around here right
earlier they were buying it around the
47 900 down to about you know 47 850 so
about this 50 area here now they're
coming in here later
at
you know the 47 850 47
880 area you can see 55
transacted on the offer 54 transact so a
hundred right a hundred came in here
a hundred
sell it you know there's a hundred
bitcoin that sold on the offer so what
that means is people came in and they
offered it out they put it on the offer
for the buyers to come in and buy it i
mean i don't know if it was some of
these people that bought it here right
thinking this market's going to go
higher they took
they took some heat as the market sold
off and it came back up here now they're
thinking oh this is it now we're going
to get paid and then they didn't then as
it starts coming down
around the level that they bought it at
you know they think you know they you
know we had our run to go higher and it
didn't happen so now they start offering
it out
right so you're seeing sort of the
opposite you're seeing that um strong
passive buying in here right to support
the market that didn't work the market
came back up to around the break even
level tried to go a little bit higher
didn't now it's starting to fall back
down so now you know even though this
this market here now
right is starting to come off this
they're taking their opportunity to get
out right and they're offering out 55 54
they're probably offering more but
that's what traded there's the 55 and
the 54. right and they are basically
putting it out there
so the buyers could come in you know the
the
i hate to say dumb money but you know
the money that the people that i think
in this market still going higher
they're just happy to buy it here oh you
know hey you know buy the dip right we
just went up to 48 you know whatever
48.50
and starting to come down now i can buy
about you know almost 100 bucks cheaper
so they're buying it but you have those
big sellers coming in here
right they're not pushing the market
down it's not in their interest to start
hitting these bids you know the people
that bought it here earlier it's not in
their interest to get out by hitting all
these bids in here and move the market
down if they can start piecing it out
you know just offer it out offer it out
you know maybe they iceberg their order
whatever
they're happy to keep selling it out
here and just scratch this trade because
they know
for whatever reason right now this
market isn't going any higher right now
okay now it starts dropping you know
they lower their offers down to you know
the 800 area
okay i mean that you know you got some
earlier buyers coming in here 40 25 46
because they realize you know the people
that bought here earlier i realized this
move isn't
isn't manifesting it's not happening
okay they're happy to get out
now you know scratch the trade take a
tiny tiny loss
and wait for the next opportunity to
come along because if they don't get out
here
all right what happens market starts
selling off more
and it gets down here to this
6 you know 630 area
and there's a big bid here that trades
111 bitcoin that's big all right that
should hold the market
and it doesn't it just goes right
through it just sort of gets swept right
through from 47
you know 630 all the way down below 47
600 it comes all the way down to around
this the 570 area so about a 50 move it
just gets whacked right here
then you got another big bid that
sitting in the book here around the
540 area just below 550 right another
hundred
so you got 111 101 so that's 200 bitcoin
right in here that is not holding up the
market
okay so what did you have you had buying
here earlier right that should have held
up the market it didn't the market just
sold right down through it right sort of
came back up now you're seeing the big
sellers coming in here around that same
level right coming in on the offer
they're offering it out they're keeping
their
proverbial foot on the neck of the
market
55 54 another 52
right
market drops down okay well that's fine
you know i got a big bid here 47 630.
whoops it traded all the way through it
down to the next big big here
at 47 540 traded right through that too
these are signs of a weak market
okay now it's not a sign of a weak
market um that you can go and buy and
hold for three months right when you're
trading order flow you're trading
the now right you're trading what's
happening right now in the market you're
not buying and holding right that's a
different type of of trading altogether
so you got this big sweep through the
book right so you got a hundred that
just got hit 100 that got hit here
and all this void all this no counter
trade in here all these zeros
okay market sold off some more got all
the way down to
47 you know 120
bounced back up to where where you had
that aggressive selling
okay and then it just stopped right
there because why those aggressive
sellers that were there they're probably
still sitting up here right when people
you know when the big traders are out
there selling
you know they
people don't understand you know when
when big traders are
active in the market they're looking for
size to trade against because they don't
necessarily want to move the market
and you know if someone is in a position
and you know they want to get out of 200
bitcoin and they get out of it right in
here that's fine they're happy rather
than getting out of 200 bitcoin and
dropping it you know two three hundred
dollars if they could just move at fifty
dollars that's a good
that's a that's that's an excellent
trade for them
then
they probably still got some residual
okay fine you know i could you know
their average price is somewhere up in
here around 47 550.
they could just work whatever left they
got right up here so if the market comes
back up they start to sell it again
which they do right and then the market
drops from 550
all the way down to
650 and it'll probably triggered other
sellers coming in here right now the
market did bounce back
okay obviously
um bounce back pretty quick
and where are we right now and right now
we're sort of around this five you know
this area that
you had the big aggressive selling going
on um well now we're a bit lower here
trading around 300
so it'll be interesting i'm looking at
this level here this 47 200
if it can hold or not you know because
earlier
you have this big blue zone right which
is a sign of of um
trapped traders which should hold as
support so you know i'll be interested
to see if it comes down in here
and can hold and then bounce back up or
not right here we got some aggressive
sellers coming in obviously got this all
these imbalances
um
so we'll see you know it's
again it's um
it's an interesting market it follows
overflow really nice
but right now there's not too much going
on again you know what time is it it's
about five in the afternoon
in chicago so it's kind of a quiet time
before asia kicks off
but
you know we're seeing some pretty small
deltas in the
markets you know 12 6
8 so trading has kind of quieted down
but we'll see if this 47 200
you know the 47 100 if this area can
hold in here as support then you know
i'd look for a
move
back up maybe back up to these highs up
here 47 900
maybe a run at 47 800 if not if this
breaks and trade through here obviously
um
the move would be to the downside so
anyway guys you know i hope you found
this interesting
it's uh you know crypto's interesting
market you know maybe later i'll do one
on on dogecoin um because dogecoin in my
opinion follows order flow really nicely
i mean you can see it right here right
you got that big selling zone where the
market sold off came right back up into
it and held and sold off some more so
anyway guys you know if you found this
interesting
put a thanks in the comments section be
sure to like and subscribe to the
channel
and take care everyone bye-bye